il symbolise un univers de luxe
d'aventure et de sport fait une
croisière à travers le temps grâce à ses
vaisseaux en tout genre à voile ou à
moteur du haut de glacis au bateau de
sport jusqu'au palais flottant bienvenue
dans le monde des bateaux de plaisance
[Musique]
l'expérience en bateau à voile ou grâce
à la puissance d'un moteur vous emporte
au-delà du temps nous voilà sur l'eau
enivré par le vent le soleil et la
fraîcheur de l’air qui se mélangent dans
une sensation presque insoutenable nos
sangs sont tout à coup ravivés par le
désir d'échapper à tout et à la passion
de l'aventure il y a toujours un côté
enfant qui reste en nous et lorsqu'on
vieillit le bateau nous donne encore la
chance d'exprimer notre côté puéril je
pense que la plus grande différence
entre les adultes et les enfants et
peut-être le prix des jouets qu'ils
utilisent
on peut trouver ces jouets partout dans
le monde du sud de la Californie où l'on
peut voir bon nombre de yachts du style
Catalina un débatto à voile les plus
populaires de la région
jusqu'au lac Michigan lieu par
excellence de provenance des yachts
des yacht Palmer Johnson au terrain de
jeu des millionnaires à Fort de l'Eau
d'Heure Dale et à temps bye en Floride
où les yacht lizers melt tradition et
technologie de pointe
en Italie design et luxe sont les
véritables ancres de la compagnie de
yacht asomut Benetti
aux Pays-Bas nous trouvons la compagnie
fathip qui se place en tête de la
construction des plus grands yachts du
monde grâce à sa ligne prestigieuse de
bateau
ou que nous allions le bateau de
plaisance assure sa domination
le
battre
à ce niveau-là et de toute évidence
réservée au plus grosses fortunes cela a
commencé il y a des milliers d'années
dans les cercles exclusifs de la royauté
bien que les documents historiques
soient peu nombreux on sait que
Cléopâtre aimé se promener sur ce genre
d'embarcation
certainement le meilleur type
d'embarcation du Nil elle en est avec
elle des musiciens toutes sortes de
boissons à son goût et des esclaves en
charge de ramer elle a même sucé-lui un
Marc Antoine sur cette embarcation
les Grecs et les Romains se sont
également pris d'intérêt pour les
plaisirs du bateau lorsque leur marin
était ni à la guerre ni occupé à
protéger les routes commerciales et il
se livrait à des courses les uns contre
les autres pour évaluer leur force
le bateau de plaisance est très vite
devenu une mode en Europe dès qu'on lui
donnait un nom un rêve est né
le mot yacht est à l'origine monnaie
irlandais
au 16e et 17e siècle les croisières
étaient très prisées au Pays-Bas malgré
des débuts sans prétention
[Musique]
était des bateaux commerciaux qui
transportaient des cochons des vaches et
des grains et utiliser comme bateau de
plaisance pendant le week end
au 17ème siècle alors que les
Néerlandais se sont mis à affirmer leur
supériorité dans la construction navale
la royauté et la bourgeoisie ont
commencé à faire construire des yachts
destinés à faire de la voile de
plaisance sur les canaux d'Amsterdam
les aristocrates avaient des bateaux de
plaisance dont il se servait
particulièrement le dimanche ils
emmenaient avec eux des plats déguster
afin d'avoir un genre de pique-nique sur
l'eau c'est ainsi qu'Amsterdam a marqué
le début du yachting les courses de
bateaux et le yachting sont ainsi
devenus des passe-temps des
propriétaires de yacht ont commencé à
parier en faisant des courses contre
d'autres propriétaires ce qui a donné
lieu à des jeux organisés
[Musique]
mais l'homme est par nature est pris de
compétition alors quand ta marin
néerlandais a vu son voisin le dépasser
en bateau il s'est dit en lui-même mon
bateau est plus rapide que ça c'est
probablement de cette façon que les
cours sont commencés et sont devenus
très compétitives au Pays-Bas au 18e et
19e siècle le yachting s'est répandu en
Angleterre en Europe et en Amérique
alors que les propriétaires de yacht les
plus fortunés ont commencé à faire
construire des yachts suivant leurs
exigences et organiser des yacht clubs
un des plus populaires était le
contre-avoine c'était un petit bateau de
vitesse à voile il avait un seul homme
monté à l'avant et à l'arrière portant
la voile principale et les deux voiles
de l'avant sa cale était profonde et
étroite et possédait un beau près
[Musique]
l'apparence des nouveaux yachts a été
influencée par le succès du schooner une
Golette appelée America
ce type de bateau a été construit par
George steels pour un Yacht Club de New
York à la tête duquel se trouvait John
Stevens
comme nous le montre cette réplique en
bois du bateau américain ses ponts et sa
coque possèdent des lignes bien plus
claires que celles de ses prédécesseurs
[Musique]
il avait aussi le maximum de sa largeur
plus près de la poupe que les bateaux de
course précédent son étrave était aussi
plus étroite
en concurrence avec les meilleurs yachs
de Britanniques l'Amica a donné son nom
à la coupe d'Amérique après sa victoire
remarquable à calls en 1851
[Musique]
tente une goélette aussi appelée
schooner le scooter est ainsi devenu
très en vogue avant cela le type Cutter
est né sur les eaux mais le scooner a
pris le dessus est devenu un vrai bateau
de course que beaucoup d'Américains
voulaient imiter de nombreuses couleurs
ont été construits durant cette période
l'ère de la révolution industrielle a
amené l'utilisation de la machine à
vapeur qui a eu un grand succès dans le
milieu naval les gens les plus fortunés
se sont mis à faire de grandes
croisières devenu leur passe en favori
un sens de l'esthétisme extrêmement
développé était à l'origine de cette
nouvelle passion
le yachting moderne est né à la même
époque que le mouvement romantique
artistique et culturel le plus précoce
et on a ainsi trouvé dans l'océan de la
beauté de l'harmonie et de la paix
je pense que ce sont ces mêmes
sentiments que les gens recherchent
toujours aujourd'hui
les premiers yachts possédaient des
roues dotés d'aviron
ensuite on est passé à des yachts dotés
d'un moteur à hélice complètement
submergé dans l'eau ce concept était
élégant dans sa simplicité alors qu'une
lame angulaire tournée le mouvement
poussait l'eau vers l'arrière ce qui
faisait avancer le bateau
[Musique]
le méflower était un bateau à vapeur il
avait été construit à l'origine pour
hotden Golette un leader de l'immobilier
américain puis avait été vendu à la
marine américaine en 1898 le navire
pesait 2690 tonnes et contenait un
moteur extrêmement puissant à deux
hélices doté d'une grande force de
propulsion
le navire nécessitait un équipage de
plus de 150 personnes
de 1906 à 1929 le méflower a servi de
navires officiels au président des
États-Unis
[Musique]
en Virginie le USS willansbourg le
nouveau navire du président Truman a été
réaménagé et il joue le rôle de maison
blanche sur mer tout en étant un lieu de
loisirs pour notre chef d'État dont
l'emploi du temps est chargé on a rendu
les appartements présidentielles aussi
confortables que possible pour qu'il
puisse travailler se décontracter en
recevant des personnalités
le Lénor a également été un navire
important Eisenhower appelait le Barbara
Anne et Jeff Kennedy le honey feet
certains des navires ont donc changé de
nom suivant les changements de président
au pouvoir
[Musique]
à la fin du 19e et au début du 20e
siècle les plus célèbres yachts étaient
la propriété d'une grande entreprise
financière à la tête de laquelle se
trouvait Jippy Morgan comme au bord du
yacht club de New York
son bateau corserve number free faisait
environ 103 mètres de long et
fonctionner à la vapeur
[Musique]
on recevait les invités avec générosité
sur ses navires qui étaient assez
modernes pour l'époque mais à la
réflexion ils étaient assez simples et
primaires au point de vue construction
le système de plomberie de toilette y
était minimale
[Musique]
mais c'est navire avait des limites et
comprenait certains problèmes
on devait prendre une benne de charbon
et sur un bateau de 120 mètres de long
la moitié ou même deux tiers de l'espace
était occupé par la benne de charbon et
le système de fonctionnement
en 1913 Alexander Winton a changé tout
cela c'est lui qui a introduit le moteur
à combustion interne et à essence dans
les navires de grande taille
[Musique]
dans les années 20 une version maritime
des moteurs diesel a été adopté ce
qu'est donné plus de puissance au bateau
tout en étant économique
[Musique]
il y avait aussi plus d'espace pour
organiser les intérieurs luxueux
[Musique]
les bateaux à voile pouvaient comprendre
également un moteur que l'on pouvait
utiliser pour se déplacer au port ou
lorsque le vent était insuffisant
ces bateaux étaient appelés yacht
auxiliaires
[Musique]
le plus grand voilier de ce type
construit est toujours en fonction
aujourd'hui et le Hussard doté de quatre
mâts
il sera plus tard appelé le cycloud il
possédait une voile d'environ 10 mille
mètres carrés qui flottait
majestueusement en mer
[Musique]
c'était en 1931 après 50 constructions
que Madame automne épouse d'un grand
financier a posé le regard pour la
première fois sur ce chef-d'oeuvre que
son époux lui offrait pour son
anniversaire
bien que les huttons n’est jamais révélé
le prix de cette construction le coût a
dû s'élever à ce qui serait de nos jours
une somme d'environ 100 millions de
dollars le navire était pourvu de 34
cabines privées d'un luxe incomparable
dans les années 70 ça restera Sion a
coûté 7 millions de dollars
aujourd'hui le cycloud est un bateau de
croisière
[Musique]
une des raisons pour lesquelles ces
navires sont toujours en service
reposent sur le fait que l'on attache
une certaine valeur commerciale à
l'aspect mystique des époques passées il
est également certain qu'il serait plus
onéreux d'entreprendre de telles
constructions que de les restaurer
tout comme le cycloud le Savarona a
commencé sa carrière en 1931
avec un pont du longueur de 123 mètres
le navire est devenu le jouet de
l'héritière de la plus grande compagnie
métallurgique américaine Émilie cadeau
en dépit de sa grande fortune elle a
refusé de payer la taxe de luxe aux
États-Unis elle n'a donc pas pu faire
escale en Amérique
elle n'a pas pu ainsi impressionner ses
amis de New York puisqu'elle n'est
jamais allée en Amérique en conséquence
elle a décidé de mettre le navire en
vente il est assez curieux de remarquer
qu'Adolf Hitler était une des premières
personnes intéressées par le navire en
1936 finalement le navire a été vendu à
la Turquie pour servir de yacht
présidentielle il est toujours en
service sur la Méditerranée à Istanbul
et son maintien coûte environ 20
millions de dollars
le yacht a été restauré en 1992 il
possède 18 suites accessibles à un usage
privé mais avant d'appeler votre agence
de voyage notez que le séjour sur ce
yacht coûte 40 000 $ par jour
dans les années 20 les yachts étaient la
propriété de ceux qui essayaient de
vivre comme Eve Scott Fitzgerald dans le
film great godsby
mais après le crash boursier de Wall
Street en 1929 les États-Unis ont sombré
dans une crise économique sans précédent
et seulement les plus fortunés pouvaient
encore faire du yachting
dans les années 30 la popularité des
grands navires a subi un certain déclin
on s'est alors retourné vers la
construction de yacht de taille plus
modéré et de prix plus bas
[Musique]
un coup moins élevé et une production de
masse on dynamisé le marché des yachts
du coup les loisirs de weekend ont pris
un nouvel aspect
jusqu'au 20e siècle la construction
navale se faisait manuellement et l'on
ne produisait qu'un bateau à la fois
c'est ainsi que les bateaux de plaisance
étaient coûteux et donc hors de porter
pour la plupart des gens leur
possibilité se limiter à de simples
bateaux à rames et à de petits voiliers
faits maison ce n'était pas très
exaltant mais tout cela allait bientôt
changer grâce à Oli Evin Road un
Américain d'origine norvégienne il est
considéré comme le père des moteurs
hors-bord
on dit que Holly Evenrude est allé faire
du bateau à rames sur un lac dans le
Wisconsin et qu'on lui avait demandé de
ramener de la glace
il est allé chercher la glace en
question mais à la fondue avant qu'il
ait eu le temps de la ramener il s'est
donc dit qu'il fallait trouver un moyen
plus rapide de rejoindre la rive
à l'époque le système de propulsion
utilisé pour les bateaux sans voile
était un type de moteur en bord ce type
d'embarcation avait un moteur fixé sur
la coque avec un arbre de transmission
dans la partie centrale qui faisait
tourner l'hélice
c'est écouteux et Evin Wood a commencé à
chercher une alternative
à partir de 1909 il a développé le
premier moteur extérieur à la coque il
s'agissait d'un moteur à un cylindre et
d'une puissance d'un chevau 5
[Musique]
ce moteur externe est portable et
comprend un arbre de transmission et une
hélice fixée verticalement le moteur est
vissé à l'arrière du bateau
en 1910 Oli Evin roods a fondé la
compagnie evil win Motors à Milwaukee ce
nouveau projet ambitieux a eu un énorme
succès
[Musique]
il a popularisé les moteurs il a trouvé
quelque chose qui fonctionnait et qui
était relativement bon marché ça se
mettait à l'arrière du bateau et ça
permettait aux gens de naviguer sur les
lacs vous voyez on a un prix très
abordable
tout comme evenwood Christopher Colombus
Smith a donné la possibilité à de
nombreux Américains de pouvoir devenir
propriétaire d'un bateau avec son frère
Henri il s'était consacré à la
construction manuelle de bateau de
plaisance pour les fortunés et cela
depuis la fin du 19e siècle
dans les années 20 Smith qui était le
fondateur de Chris krooft s'est rendu
compte que la bourgeoisie représentait
un nouveau marché il a donc changé sa
technique commerciale et emprunter
l'idée innovatrice de la production en
masse qui avait alors transformé
l'industrie automobile et a commencé à
l'utiliser pour construire des bateaux
dans son usine à algonac dans le
Michigan
la méthode traditionnelle consistait à
avoir un groupe d'artisans dédiés à un
projet du début jusqu'à la fin dans les
usines de Chris kraff et Chris Smith
halgonak le travail se faisait à la
chaîne et en 1922 il construisait un
bateau à moteur par jour en 1929 il
produisait des dizaines de milliers de
bateaux
[Musique]
Christopher Smith a rendu ce genre de
bateau accessible à beaucoup de gens ils
ont remarqué qu'il pouvait s'offrir ce
sport et que cela pouvait être une
activité familiale c'était le début de
l'accessibilité du bateau pour les
masses
Chris Craft construisait des bateaux à
moteur de haute performance en acajou
avec une option de moteur d'une
puissance de 125 chevaux et atteignant
une vitesse d'environ 54 km heure
la compagnie a introduit également des
bateaux pourvu de cabines de plus grande
taille
konéway est un autre innovateur qui est
une idée de génie au bon moment il a
amené le changement de matériaux dans la
construction de la coque des bateaux et
le passage du bois à la fibre de verre
tout d'abord fait des cercueils en fibre
de verre et puis la perfectionner sa
technique afin de pouvoir l'appliquer à
la construction nautique il a donc été
l'un des premiers établir une méthode et
une durée assurant le durcissement de la
fibre de verre
en 1959 connyre a fondé qui a contribué
à la popularisation du bateau de
plaisance
aujourd'hui si loin est une des seules
compagnies qui construit des bateaux de
plaisance pour tous les goûts
Mercury marine a été fondé il y a
environ 60 ans lorsque son fondateur
Karl caiper a pris la direction d'une
usine de bateau à moteur alors en
difficulté il a fabriqué des moteurs de
meilleure qualité que ses prédécesseurs
et son bateau Lightning à 10 chevaux a
eu du succès
au cours des années le moteur Mercury a
bien évolué et son moteur de haute
performance va maintenant jusqu'à 470
chevaux
[Musique]
les moteurs Mercury sont fabriqués dans
une usine utilisant les technologies les
plus avancées à fond du lac dans le
vinconscie des robots des ordinateurs
ainsi que les ouvriers spécialisés créer
des moteurs avec une précision digne du
21e siècle
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'industrie la
compagnie produit toutes sortes de
moteurs des hors-bord des hors-bord et
aussi les transmissions en Z Stern drive
sous le nom de mère Cruiser une branche
de Mercury
nous avons un hybride qui est une
combinaison d'un moteur intérieur et
extérieur en plaçant le moteur à
l'extrait arrière du bateau et en
sortant la transmission qui ressemble à
une partie de hors-bord à l'extérieur du
bateau aujourd'hui c'est notre inboard
outboard
s ce qui est le but de nos navigateurs
l'arbre d'hélice pouvait être de plus
grande taille ainsi que l'hélice
au début des années 90 les fabricants de
moteurs tels que Mercury Yamaha ont
porté leur attention sur l'environnement
et ont commencé à produire des moteurs
de bateau à 4 cycles au lieu de 2 les
moteurs à 4 cycles sont plus silencieux
et moins polluants
avec l'avance de la technologie des
moteurs marins la structure des coques a
aussi évolué il y a deux types de coques
pour les bateaux à moteur le modèle le
plus ancien a une coque sentir en dos en
forme de V et un fond arrondi déplaçant
l'eau lors de la navigation
il est ainsi pas très rapide
un modèle plus récent est un navire de
type tricec qui possède un fond plus
plat ce qui l'a rendu plus rapide
lorsqu'il accélère le bateau remonte
vers la surface et glisse sur l'eau
réduisant ainsi la résistance et la
friction entre la coque et l'eau
[Musique]
tout comme les premiers yachts se sont
transformés en bateau de course on a pu
voir le même type de transformation
s'effectue dans la section des bateaux à
moteur
il y a toujours ceux qui veulent aller
plus vite que les gens autour d'eux et
c'est ce qui a donné aujourd'hui le
hors-bord ou l'hydroglisseur que l'on
peut utiliser sur le lac ou sur un
fleuve
l'Hydroptère est un type d'hydroglisseur
qui comporte de petites ailes ou
platines reliées par des haubans au bas
de la coque
alors que le bateau accélère les
platines placées vers le fond poussent
le bateau vers la surface et lui permet
de se trouver à plusieurs centimètres
au-dessus de l'eau en allant ainsi assez
vite
l'Hydroptère a été mise au point en 1919
par le célèbre Alexander Graham Bell son
bateau de type HD4 pouvait atteindre la
vitesse record à l'époque de 107 km
heure
[Musique]
donne à irino qui faisait de la course
de bateau a donné le nom de bateau
cigarettes pour les bateaux rapides de
type long et ouvert
le nom vient de la forme allongée du
bateau et de leur victoire facile où il
brûlait en quelque sorte les étapes
aérino est aussi à l'origine d'autres
marques comme Donzy et formula
[Musique]
il a construit quelques-uns des bateaux
les plus rapides et des plus attrayants
qui existent
aujourd'hui les bateaux cigarettes aux
longues coques sont aussi grands que les
petits yachts
leurs coût va de 120 000 $ à 220 000
dollars
équipé de moteur mercreaser 500
possédant chacun une puissance de 470
chevaux ils atteignent une vitesse de
135 km heure
[Musique]
tout comme donne à erino Reed Henson lui
aussi a commencé sa carrière en faisant
des courses de bateau et c'est ensuite
tourné vers le commerce Edson a formé sa
propre compagnie Bayer
[Musique]
il a été le premier à reconnaître qu'il
était nécessaire de rendre les choses
plus simples pour l'acheteur grâce à lui
on avait plus besoin d'acheter un bateau
ensuite essayer de trouver un moteur
trouver quelqu'un pour l'équiper puis
trouver une remorque non la compagnie
s'occupait de tout et vous pouviez
rentrer avec un bateau fini attaché à
votre remorque
les compagnies Bayliner et searra se
sont placés en tête des marques de
bateau de plaisance
leur succès dans le commerce du bateau
vient de leur motivation et de leur
passion pour leur métier
motivation et passion se transforment en
gain financier avec 25 milliards de
dollars en vente par année le bateau
dépasse les sports et distraction en se
plaçant en tête de cette industrie aux
États-Unis
de son côté l'art de la voile a connu un
long chemin depuis l'utilisation des
voiles en toile de coque et de mains en
bois ce type d'embarcation a connu une
évolution remarquable
alors que les bateaux à moteur ont
établi leur dominance au 20e siècle la
voile a captivé de nouveaux adeptes de
10 à 20% des gens qui font du bateau
sont pris d'intérêt pour la voile ce qui
est à la fois curieux et intéressant
[Musique]
la voile pour le plaisir ou la course
est une des formes les plus anciennes de
yachting et de bateaux de plaisance
les passionnés de la voile aiment se
retrouver dans le vent utiliser une
source d'énergie gratuite ne pas
entendre de bruit de moteur ne pas
sentir de fumée c'est une sensation
remarquable lorsque le voilier commence
à avancer et qu'il vous entraîne vers
l'océan
au cours du siècle dernier
particulièrement dans les 50 dernières
années le voilier a bénéficié des
progrès de la technologie tout comme la
production en masse à révolutionner
l'industrie du bateau à moteur elle a
influencé d'une manière similaire la
construction des voiliers
il y a eu beaucoup de changements dans
la construction des voiliers de la coque
jusqu'aux voile et homard
les bateaux à voile sont passés de
l'utilisation de bois comme le chêne et
la cajou à celle de la lumière et de la
fibre de verre
la compagnie Catalina yacht à Hollande
Hill en Californie est une des leaders
de la construction américaine de yacht
dans la catégorie de 6 à 15 mètres
notre méthode de construction repose sur
une fabrication manuelle de la fibre de
verre les ouvriers coupent la fibre de
verre en rouleau et la place dans un
moule qui est ensuite mouillé à l'aide
d'un seau et d'une brosse
ils utilisent peu de résine pour
catalyser pour enduire la fibre de verre
qui est ensuite raclée on doit maintenir
une proportion de 50 à 60% entre la
résine et la fibre de verre ce qui est
optimal pour obtenir un mélange solide
plutôt que lourd
le mât et les haubans sont passés du
bois à l'aluminium et à la fibre de
carbone Jim Shay directeur de marketing
pour la compagnie l'ours marine groupe
pense que cela représentait une grande
amélioration
dans la construction des bateaux on
considère en priorité l'importance du
gréement dans le passé il était fait en
épinette ce qui demandait beaucoup de
travail de maintien en le protégeant
avec du vernis ou en nettoyant
aujourd'hui on utilise de l'aluminium et
le maintien est facile on le nettoie et
on le cire une fois par an
les voiles sont passées du coton
égyptien et du lin à des tissus
synthétiques comme le dacron
[Musique]
l'industrie de la voile a aussi
découvert des méthodes nouvelles pour
les coutures pour répartir le poids des
voiles différemment de façon à
intensifier la vitesse
les cordes ont été remplacées par de
nouveaux modèles en nylon et en matière
synthétique
[Musique]
sur les petits voiliers les taquets
utilisés par les marins sont à présent
fibre de carbone
et moitié de je guette on peut se servir
du support pour ne pas avoir à porter
tout le poids de l'équipement
c'est une méthode à l'ancienne et avant
le support était fait de bois
mais de nos jours le support est doté
d'un appareillage qui permet de tenir
l'ensemble en place
le procédé est très simple regardez
les mouvements que l'on devait faire
avant l'utilisation de ce support
exigeait le déplacement de beaucoup de
poids ce n'est plus nécessaire
la plupart des voiliers sont de nos
jours de type auxiliaire ce qui veut
dire qu'ils sont pourvus d'un moteur qui
peut prendre le relais
les conditions météo sont essentielles
pour les voiliers mais cela ne veut pas
dire que l'on ne peut pas avancer
puisque le voilier possède un moteur qui
permet une vitesse de quelques nœuds
lorsqu'il y a assez de vent les lisses
s'arrête et ne fait plus avancer le
voilier alors on doit s'en remettre
uniquement à l'utilisation des voiles
le sloop dans la catégorie des voiliers
est devenu le modèle le plus commun il
possède un phoque et une voile
principale
[Musique]
mais ce qui compte le plus c'est l'art
de la voile
il y a une centaine d'années Joshua
socum a prouvé ses ambitions et ses
qualités de marin on peut accomplir des
choses remarquables avec de l'expérience
[Musique]
dans les moyens financiers étaient très
modestes à trouver sur une plage un
bateau en très mauvais état qu'il a
réparé et avec lequel il a ensuite fait
le tour du monde
de 1895 à 1898 slowcom a fait le tour du
monde en solitaire sur un bateau de 11
mètres de long
aujourd'hui Bruce choix veut faire un
voyage similaire de 40 000 km dans une
course qui s'appelle le Vendée Globe
[Musique]
pour la course en solitaire il est très
important que le bateau puisse suivre la
direction donnée en pilotage automatique
de telle sorte que vous puissiez vous
reposer et dormir
vous ne dormez jamais longtemps mais
vous pouvez faire des petits sommets
vous lever toutes les heures pour tout
vérifier on contrôle les instruments qui
indiquent la direction du vent celle du
bateau il y a aussi le système de
pilotage automatique tout cela
fonctionne grâce à un ordinateur
le constructeur italien périmé la vie
aime beaucoup ce système sa compagnie a
donc créé une ligne de bateau regroupant
l'art de la voile à une technologie de
pointe ce sont des navires complètement
automatiques
[Musique]
normalement sur un voilier d'une
longueur de 50 mètres et d'une surface
de voile de 1500 mètres carrés il faut
un équipage de 15 personnes à bord pour
manœuvrer la voile avec ce système il
n'y a qu'une personne le capitaine qui
fait à peu près tout
leur technologie est aussi étonnante que
leur prix on ne peut pas acheter un
bateau de ce type pour moins de 20
millions de dollars
nous allons maintenant porter le regard
vers le sommet du luxe et de la
technologie nautique
[Musique]
dans l'univers restreint où l'argent ne
présente aucun obstacle les
constructeurs européens du yacht ont
créé le méga yacht dans le luxe la
technologie et le confort demeurent sans
pareil
[Musique]
il y a plus de yachts d'une longueur des
passes en 24 mètres en construction en
Italie que dans n'importe quel autre
pays du monde à villereggio en Italie
l'art de la voile et de la construction
des bateaux remonte au 15e siècle
c'est comme quelque chose d'inné chez la
plupart des gens de cette ville de la
côte italienne
[Musique]
tous les matins les pêcheurs jettent
leurs filets dans la Méditerranée qui
leur permet ainsi de gagner leur vie
sur le port les poissonniers vendent
bruyamment les fruits de la pêche des
poissons et des crevettes
et juste au cours de la rue on retrouve
l'entreprise bennettillante une filiale
de asmod Benetti ce constructeur de
yacht est actuellement en possession de
la plus grande commande de mégaillots au
monde
l'avantage de construire des yachts à
villarregio repoussent sur une longue
tradition de yachting dans la technique
est vraiment au point
la philosophie de Benetti ne consiste
pas à construire de grands yachts mais
des bateaux de luxe d'un luxe
exceptionnel comme vous pouvez vous-même
le remarquer
[Musique]
en dépit de tous les éléments luxueux
que l'on peut trouver à bord des bateaux
Benetti ces derniers concerts d'une
certaine légèreté ce qui les rend
relativement rapide ils peuvent rester à
une vitesse de croisière de 20 nœuds le
prix de ce genre de bateau peut
atteindre des dizaines de millions de
dollars
[Musique]
pour ceux qui ne sont pas acheteurs il y
a une alternative à 150 km de Gênes en
Italie se déroule le 13e congrès
international des locations de yacht
c'est là que se retrouve les
propriétaires de yacht et les négociants
présentant ainsi un marché nautique
extraordinaire de par sa variété
[Musique]
cet endroit ne pouvait pas être mieux
choisi car c'est la ville de naissance
de Christophe Colomb et là où il a
découvert sa passion pour la navigation
dans ce voilier centenaire aux formes
classiques on retrouve toute la passion
et l'attrait de l’aventure nautique
le propriétaire du myt summer doit être
passionné par les bateaux classiques
c'est une ambiance complètement
différente de celle des bateaux à moteur
qu'on ne trouve pas à bord de moto
marine ou de bateaux de vitesse on est
là que pour se décontracter
les goûts varient au point de vue du
choix Pearl fouge par exemple est un
voilier moderne dans le profil
technologique ressemble à celui de
médecin
des voiliers les bateaux à moteur sont
les plus populaires
dotés de milliers de chevaux et de
réservoirs à essence d'une taille
considérable ce type de bateau possède
des chambres somptueuses
on y trouve des salons confortables et
des ponts qui incitent au bain de soleil
ce sont les merveilles des grandes
fortunes
les propriétaires de ces types de yacht
sont en général à la tête de grandes
entreprises ce sont généralement des
entrepreneurs ils sont indépendants
quelquefois un peu trop sûrs
nécessaires pour réaliser leurs projets
s'est installé au Pays-Bas où l'on
trouve les origines du yaching il est le
descendant de constructeur de yacht
néerlandais qui ont su impressionner le
monde au 16e et 17e siècle
étant reconnu comme la Rolls-Royce des
mégaillots sa construction de bateau
s'est centré sur des modèles de plus de
48 mètres de long comportant des coques
en acier
[Musique]
ceux qui veulent se lancer dans la
construction de yacht de luxe espère
régaler la qualité de l'entreprise faite
ship cette qualité est issue d'une
longue expérience que l'on ne peut
obtenir en un ou deux ou cinq ou même 10
ans
bien officiellement fait ship n'était
fondé qu'en 1949 les trois compagnies
dont elle est issue remontent à
plusieurs générations
grâce à cette expérience ancestrale de
nombreux propriétaires ont su faire
confiance à la société et lui accorder
les fonds nécessaires à la construction
de ces yacht absolument remarquable que
fait ship continue à construire l'un
après l'autre
les Européens sont en tête du marché
mais pas pour longtemps nous allons voir
que les Américains prennent de la
vitesse
alors que les Européens ont jusqu'à
présent dominer l'univers des mégaillots
les Américains ont acquis une certaine
avance au point de vue concurrence tout
en observant leurs prédécesseurs
[Musique]
la compagnie Laza radio
et son frère Brad qui peuvent retracer
leur héritage nautique jusqu'à la
Méditerranée
[Musique]
mon grand-père était d'un petit port de
pêche à côté de Palerme en Sicile et ma
grand-mère était apparentée un capitaine
de Gênes mon père était un des pionniers
de l'industrie au début des années 50 et
depuis nous construisons des bateaux
la compagnie la Zara utilise ce qu'on
appelle Isis un système d'information
intégré au bateau
ce système régule en permanence le
fonctionnement électrique et mécanique
du bateau tout en étant capable de
conserver les informations obtenues
c'est une manière de grouper les
informations vitales pour le bon
fonctionnement du yacht
toutes ces données sont ensuite ramenées
à l'usine ou des ingénieurs les analyses
et en font un registre qui servira à
améliorer nos constructions
en 1998 Palmer Johnson un constructeur
du wiscansi à innové en présentant le
yacht américain le plus grand depuis la
crise économique des années 30 c'est un
yacht d'environ 59 mètres de long
appelés la barre Renaissance
cette ville flottante peut faire un
parcours de 15000 km son prix n'en est
pas moins spectaculaire 35 millions de
dollars
de plus ce yacht nécessite environ 15
litres d'essence par kilomètre
[Musique]
il est fascinant de penser que l'on
n'aurait jamais imaginé il y a 20 ans
qu'un yacht pourrait posséder un tel
confort et un tel luxe le changement est
donc assez marquant
au-delà du luxe les ondes financières
peut aussi motiver des innovations et
des apports technologiques on a pu
connaître des changements importants
dans le progrès des systèmes de
communication et de navigation
[Musique]
dans le passé les marins naviguaient à
l'aide du soleil et des étoiles puis du
sextant et enfin d'une boussole
[Musique]
tout cela a bien changé évidemment
au côté sécurité de la navigation
lorsqu'on se retrouve à des milliers de
kilomètres ou même à 150 km de la côte
il est important de pouvoir toujours
rester en contact avec quelqu'un d'autre
grâce à la radio de pouvoir savoir la
profondeur de l'eau à l'approche du
rivage et surtout connaître la position
du bateau à un mètre 80 près
la navigation a été facilité par
l'apport de la microélectronique et les
progrès spatiaux de la mairie
les marins utilisent le GPS un système
mondial de radio pour la navigation ce
système permet au marin de calculer sa
position à n'importe quel point du globe
grâce à des ondes de radio provenant de
trois satellites et qui lui donne une
mesure exacte de sa distance
les résultats apparaissent sur un écran
le radar permet au navigateur de savoir
à quelle distance il se trouve des
autres bateaux
et le sonore permet de la former de la
profondeur de l'eau
[Musique]
une des plus importantes innovation
électronique maritime de notre époque
repose sur l'intégration de tous les
instruments de mesure dans un même
système leur permettant ainsi d'échanger
les renseignements
c'est le système sitol communication qui
a rendu cela possible en partageant les
renseignements tels que la vitesse la
profondeur les coordonnées reçues par
tous les instruments lors des
communications
aujourd'hui au congrès de Monaco on voit
les propriétaires des yacht
s'intéressaient de plus en plus à
l'alliance de l'écologie et de la
technologie
ses propriétaires sont affiliés au
domaine de la science ils appartiennent
à une organisation du nom de The
International seeker Society il s'agit
d'une association bénévole de
propriétaires de yacht de luxe qui a
pour but de rapporter des renseignements
sur la pollution des océans et sur la
pureté la température et la salinité de
l'eau l'organisation fournit à ses
membres un matériel sophistiqué
permettant de recueillir les
renseignements qui font l'objet de cette
recherche
[Musique]
un des effets positifs du nombre
important de yacht de grande taille dans
le monde c'est cette passion débordante
de leur propriétaire pour l'océan
c'est yacht sont assez grands et
capables d'aller de plus en plus loin
ils offrent la sécurité nécessaire au
croisière et comme vous pouvez le voir
vous-même l'océan est menacé
le but de ses propriétaires de méga
yacht est d'aider les scientifiques les
météorologues et les climatologues
mais en fait il n'est pas vraiment
important que le bateau de plaisance
soit bien équipé ou non ce qui est
important c'est le moment d'évasion que
l'on peut obtenir en allant sur la mer
dans un yacht ou même sur un lac dans
une barque bien que ce soit des lieux
différents les sentiments sont les mêmes
vous sentez les effets du vent vous
attrapez des coups de soleil et vous
pouvez regarder le rivage en vous disant
je suis là dans la nature on ressent
l'exaltation de se sentir soi-même et
d'être sur l'eau tout à la fois
c'est une aventure incroyable et qui est
difficile à expliquer mais quand on a pu
la vivre on veut la retrouver encore et
encore
bien que le monde est énormément changé
au fond nous sommes toujours des nomades
comme nous l'étions il y a 100 000 ans
du point de vue de la psychologie
humaine le rôle des yachts et de nous
donner la possibilité de faire ce que
nous avons toujours voulu faire
c'est-à-dire d'aller là où nous voulons
quand nous voulons y aller
[Musique]